michael thanks for for coming on the
show let's kick off with your past you
were once a mafia boss
in 1986 you were actually listed as one
of the top 50 most powerful and wealthy
mafia bosses in the
world there's a mystique in a way around
the mafia a sort of glamour and grit
are the portrayals that we see
anything like living it well it depends
on on what you're seeing and if you're
watching a movie like goodfellas
uh donnie brasco
uh even bronx tale
uh pretty authentic you know the
characters are portrayed well
and uh you know in goodfellas they
mentioned me in goodfellas and and
donnie brasco i knew all of all those
guys and i thought they did a great job
now some of the movies that you see no
but those three i would say are
uh pretty accurate when i watch gamora
which is set in italy it's set in the
slums of naples really it's gritty and
it's messy
and it's brutish
and it's a kind of horrible life
actually to watch it it's full of pathos
actually
was it like that quite a lot of the time
like it was a grind
in america there are a lot of
misconceptions you know that people draw
from the media and sometimes from
uh you know from entertainment uh things
that they watch
there is a gritty part of the life
obviously it's very gritty it's street
uh but there's also a integrity and a
respect to the life
and i think we see that in some of those
movies we saw it in the godfather even
though it was fictional
and that's what i experienced you know
there is a a high standard in that life
in many ways there's a code of conduct
yeah code of conduct
uh respect is an issue discipline is an
issue
um you know
being respectful to women believe it or
not you know your wives your families
uh it's all part of that life and there
are serious consequences if you don't
pay attention on your website um
you serve yourself that your
own the only high ranking official from
a major crime family that ever walked
away
without protective custody alive and
you're still here and you're very
successful
yes how did you do that well understand
it's not
it's not something that i portrayed
myself as but uh you don't walk away
from that life i mean you just can't you
take that oath it's for
it's for it's a lifetime oath
and normally when people leave the life
they join the government enter a witness
protection program and begin cooperating
i didn't do that
i was just
determined to walk away because i knew
it was a bad life
and i wanted to preserve my family life
after you left did you we you must have
been afraid were you you constantly
looking over your shoulder thinking
someone's going to take me out
when i walk down the street here i look
over my shoulder it's just instinct you
know from being part of that life for so
many years i didn't live in fear
because i was
i felt pretty sure that i can handle it
so i didn't live in fear but i was
cautious i wondered as well
whether
your father remained in the mafia
uh he died when we just talked about it
when he was 103.
did he offer you protection
do you think that helped you that your
father
was still active
you know yes and no um listen when i
walked away from that life the
authorities the fbi came into prison i
was in prison at the time and they said
there's a contract on your life and your
father has gone along with it that's
what they told me
you know i don't think they understood
that i knew the life that well and i
understood that my father
couldn't speak up for me at that point
because he didn't know what i was going
to do if he did go along with it it was
only to protect himself because when you
bring somebody into that life and that
person becomes an informant or
cooperator you could be in trouble
yourself for introducing him into life
how did you feel when you found out that
your father had gone along with the
contract on your life you're a father
yourself i understood what he was doing
now i want to make it clear i mean
i don't think my father would ever put a
bullet in my head i don't believe that
he did what he had to do just to
preserve himself at that point but
uh
did it hurt a little bit yeah i have to
admit it did but i understood what he
was doing and i love my dad i mean there
was nothing that he was going to do to
take into fear and the love that i had
for him and the love he had for me i
understood that
but you know the street life is
different and you have to you have to be
careful there because you know one wrong
move could be very serious
so in some ways the mafia family becomes
more important than your nuclear family
your real family
not for me but remember this feel that
yes when you take that oath
you're told straight out if your mother
is dying and sick and you're at her
bedside and we call you to service you
leave your mother you come and serve us
from now on we're number one in your
life before anything and everything so
you you have that drilled into your head
it's number one
my dad unfortunately
uh lived by that oath
to great suffering of his family i mean
i understand i had a sister that died at
the age of 27 odd on drugs my brother a
drug addict all his life became an
informant and testified against my dad
in his case my younger brother my baby
brother what happened to him
put my ba my father back in jail my
brother is now on the street he was in
witness protection for many years and i
wasn't willing to do that to my family
michael can you you've made a made man a
made member
um
you were a mate you were inducted in
1975 so 48 years ago it would be 47
years ago
can you just explain to the viewers what
what is that what what's that what was
that night like what what happens they
cut your finger right here some blood
drops on the floor i cupped my hands
they took a picture of a saint catholic
altar card put it on my hands lit it
aflame didn't hurt it burned quickly it
was merely symbolic and he said tonight
michael francis you are born again into
a new life into cousin austria violate
what you know about this life betray
your brothers and you will die
and burn in hell like the saint is
burning in your hands do you accept yes
i do that's the oath well let's get on
to london here in tottenham um
you came here to talk about the tour but
also you know in london that there's a
huge problem with knife crime in places
like tottenham lots of boroughs across
the capital
um
there's an initiative here gloves up
knifes down
would that have persuaded you years ago
in brooklyn do you think yes
these kids on the street i spent a lot
of time in prison with kids coming into
the system 21 22 years old horrible
backgrounds you know get involved in
gangs drugs the whole bit and i used to
minister and counsel to them at that
time before i was a christian i was
still a street guy at that point i said
what are you doing with your life
you know i tell them you know you keep
hanging out in these environments get
used to this because this is going to be
your home you're going to be here for
the rest of your life and you're going
to drive your family crazy if you got
one
so um but yes you need these
organizations because look
you can't just tell a kid walk away from
that life and send them back to the
neighborhood it's dangerous what caused
me when you talk about your previous
life is that the mafia is like an
alternative society it has a family it
has social bonds intergenerational
respect it has a structure it has a code
of contact
conduct it's motivated by a clear goal
which is success and protection of
members
when i think about organized crime gangs
in london
they might be less structured
but they also for the
kids that get involved in them they're a
family
it provides them with structure do you
see parallels between
between the two lives no they don't have
real structure and discipline they're
not really organized they're a bunch of
street drugs trying to steal to earn a
living and that's what they teach
it's different the gang life is
different than mafia causing arsenal we
were organized crime we had our crime
directed in a certain direction we
weren't going robbing people's houses
and and you know knifing people in the
street and stuff like that we didn't do
that my targets federal government big
banks insurance companies they got
enough money i figured hey if we take a
few bucks they'll survive we're not
robbing people in the street it's a
whole different thing that's not family
michael you've talked about we've talked
a bit about knife crime and
and and inner city crime
and you do go and talk to kids in
schools but you're also here because
you're you've got a tour where you're
going to talk about
your life yes
july 2nd at the grosvenor hotel we kick
off the tour right here in london where
we should kick it off and we're going to
25 cities throughout the united kingdom
and it's going to be fantastic i'm very
excited about it they're going to hear
about the mob life it's part of life i
know what people want to hear i've been
telling stories but i feel
i can say things here in the united
kingdom that i've never said before and
i want to give people a real insight
into that life you got to understand
something i was around john gotti fat
tony salerno de chin
uh joe colombo these were all my fellow
associates my dad sonny francis oldest
living mob guy in the world so i have a
lot to talk about a lot to tell i want
to give people real insight into that
life and they're going to hear it all
around the uk and it's going to be a fun
a fun deal
okay michael francis thank you so much
for
coming on the show thank you